normalement de
frapps
te
[Musique]
ex
[Applaudissements]
it's been difficult for almost years and
um um every day seems like I hear bad
news so every day I'm stressed and I'm
anxious so sports like this help take
things pour le but que vous comprenez on
frappe avec là
là je sais grâce à le sport que les
femmes elles peut avoir la confiance en
eux et aussi peut sortir d'isolement ça
leur aide énormément en plus les
associations kabubu qui aideent qui a
des beaucoup de différents activités
basketball la foot
Tao
le sport en fait ça rassemble ça fait d'
c'est un langage universel on n pas
besoin de parler la même langue on n pas
besoin de venir du même pays et c'est
pour ça que le sport c'est super
puissant parce que ça rassemble vraiment
des personnes qui se seraient pas
forcément rencontré par
[Musique]
ailleurs
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait très
peu de femmes exilées qui participaient
à nos activités alors que les femmes
exilées représentent 40 % des demandes
d'asile qui sont déposées en France donc
on s'est dit en fait elles sont où et
pourquoi elles viennent pas aux
activités et on a du coup créé des des
sessions de sport qui sont 100 %
féminines pour pouvoir discuter entre
femmes et pour pouvoir aussi leur créer
un espace de
confiance
mon français est amélioré puisque je
rencontre de nouveaux gens je je discute
avec eux j'ai eu de nouveaux amitié on a
fait des activités sportives culturelles
des sorties même si desjà parlaient pas
toute la même langue bah finalement on
arrivé à échanger à se faire comprendre
de d'autres façons et puis oui ben j'ai
pu discuter avec des personnes sur aussi
bah leur parcours sur le le leur
situation de demande d'asile en France
voilà sur bah leur quotidien ici qui est
très différent du
[Musique]
mien